des réfugiés de guerre il y en a très
peu dans ses pas en france qui sont nous
ce sont des réfugiés économiques
et c'est ce qui est je crois qu en tout
cas je dis pas que c'est facile à faire
mais je dis que l'opinion une dose de
droite comme de gauche notamment la
catégorie populaire est de plus en plus
demandeuses de ça et de plus en plus
alors on peut le regretter d'un point de
vue moral mais intolérante et de
plusieurs revers est d'un point de vue
moral on doit expliquer et bien
progressé et bouger les taux sont jeunes
comme vous on considère que c'est un bon
thème politique de bien de toi mais
c'est notamment qui fonctionne
exactement c'est un thème de gauche
peut-être une trêve à vous c'est pas mal
c'est de macao qu'aider on va revenir
rentrer chez vous êtes content bien sûr
du maroc soit exactement celle à
laquelle doit faire face parce que quand
on reprend la phrase de michel rocard
effectivement la france ne peut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde mais
doit prendre sa juste part
tout le problème qui a été posée ces
dernières années ces trois ou quatre
dernières années c'est que la france n'a
pas pris sa juste part alors la france à
bas prix s'est pas déplacé là très
discret non c'est parce que je dis moi
c'est ce qui est la vérité
excusez moi la france s'engage comme la
france n'a pas pris sa juste part
pourquoi pour deux raisons d'abord parce
qu'il ya eu un mouvement d'émigration
massive qui sait qui c'est qui s'est
déclenché à partir de 2013 2014
venant de syrie et d'irak effectivement
et c'est vrai les responsables
politiques de l'époque socialiste disait
ben nous on voudrait bien que dire des
gens mais il ne se dirige pas
directement vers notre pays et c'est
vrai qu'ils ont été en masse en
allemagne et aussi par une forme comme
des pays comme la suède et encore plus
au liban est aujourd'hui encore plus
solidement derrière ça il ya eu d'autres
d'autres pays effectivement où on a vu
des dvd des mouvements migratoires que
ça vienne que les gens arrivent
d'erythrée d'afghanistan ou du soudan ce
qui se passe là ce qui se passe ce qui
se passe là est allé dans les sondeurs
et aller dans les centres
mais ailleurs des débats les albanais
c'est pas comme ici des statistiques ons
a publié des idées là on a pu les donner
quand même vous reconnaissez avec
plusieurs afghans à dark en alsace
non-africains vous les reconnaissez
pardon des ménages déjà bourreau que
vous disposiez africain l'un d'eux mais
les statistiques par nationalité on les
a il y avait sept dans la rue sinon on
va dans la rue qui vous verrez que les
statistiques sont très claires la
majorité des délits migration d'amandine
relation clandestine en france vient
d'afrique la majorité de l'immigration
vous avez raison effectivement mais pas
la majorité de l'émigration de gens qui
sont réfugiées vos combats vous aviez
vos côtés si vous discutez team à la
peau voilà où je vous parle des vrais
réfugiés devraient opprimés parce qu'on
accueille des réfugiés économiques
donc il faut pas accueillir les réfugiés
que dominique soit là je te dirai
alterné petits millavois mettra pas la
canadienne quoi qu'on dise il faut bien
voir que sur la question de
l'immigration c'est pas une question
pour les prochains mois c'est une
question qui va faire que gros croître
et grandir et prendre de l'ampleur mais
il faut quand même voir les choses
telles qu'elles sont et